da gab es heute in der presse so eine
schlagzeile drosten sagt es geht erst
richtig los das kommt aus einem
interview das ich mit einem sehr weiten
zeitrahmen gespannt vor sechs acht
wochen geführt habe und das heute
veröffentlicht worden ist und daraus das
ist ein sehr langes interview und sehr
grundsätzliches interview wo es eben
darum geht dass man aus einer
perspektive mitten im sommer sagt das
wird noch mal kommen also hier geht es
jetzt nicht darum zu warnen vor der
nächsten woche oder so etwas
sondern es geht um eine weltweite
perspektive und weltweit geht es
tatsächlich jetzt richtig los
wir sind in deutschland das müssen wir
uns wirklich klar macht
in einer sonderstellung und aus der
heutigen einschätzung für die nächste
woche gibt es ja gar keinen grund sich
spezielle sorgen zu machen
aber so kurz zu blicken ist auch ganz
falsch in dieser situation wir müssen
auch für deutschland natürlich jetzt uns
das so vorstellen dass das so kommen
kann und wahrscheinlich wird wie in den
nachbarländern und uns überlegen wie wir
das in der frühphase verhindern können
und da auch den richtigen zeitpunkt
finden das ist in der unmittelbaren
nächsten zeit die größte herausforderung
im krankenhausbereich glaube ich sind
wir sehr gut vorbereitet also unsere die
kliniker sagen allgemein sie haben sehr
viel gelernt zur behandlung der
erkrankung
es ist vollkommen richtig jetzt im
moment auch die intensivbetten kapazität
wieder für etwas anderes zu nutzen
da kann man glaube ich gut planen auch
wir haben zum beispiel jetzt viel
bessere kriterien wann man überhaupt
einen patienten aufnimmt und die
bettenkapazität die damals ja geschaffen
wurde im frühjahr die lässt sich relativ
gut wieder reaktivieren weil ja viele
prozesse viele umorganisationen jetzt
einmal eingeübt worden sind in den
kliniken
wir haben aber auch andere bereiche wo
wir vielleicht weniger gut vorbereitet
sind ein ganz großer unbekannter bereich
ist ja weiterhin der bereich der schule
und wir haben ja schon im april gesehen
dass die altersgruppen eigentlich alle
so ungefähr gleichviel virus ausscheiden
und da ist jetzt aber in der zeit danach
relativ wenig noch an zusätzlicher
arbeit geleistet worden um jetzt mit
einer situation umzugehen die sich
vielleicht einstellen wird nämlich dass
die infektion in den schulen weiter
zunehmen
da haben wir jetzt doch eine sehr bunte
situation und wir müssen natürlich da
weiter genau darauf schauen und eben
auch handlungsmöglichkeiten finden wie
man schulen nicht immer gleich schließen
muss wegen ein paar fällen ohne dass man
aber eine infektion die sich
aufschaukelt nicht früh genug merkt also
man muss das natürlich sehr früh
bemerken wenn sich ein cluster einstellt
und da ist natürlich schon noch ganz
schön viel arbeit zu leisten im
organisatorischen
es müssen eben alle aufmerksam
das ist das allerwichtigste also da kann
kein ministerium und keine behörde so in
den alltag wirken wie man das eigentlich
müsste das heißt alle müssen selber
mitdenken es müssten prinzipien einfach
verstanden sein und ich glaube das ist
bei uns in deutschland sehr gut gelungen
in anderen ländern ist das nicht so in
anderen ländern weiß man in der
öffentlichkeit gar nicht was eine
erosion übertragung ist man bezweifelt
auch dass das überhaupt relevant ist und
alle desinfizieren sich ständig die
hände
und das ist ja schon so dass man hier in
deutschland da ganz schön sagen wir mal
gebildet ist
und jetzt ist eben die frage welche
entscheidung treffe ich als mit
denkender bürger für mich selbst und
mein umfeld also beispielsweise muss ich
die geburtstagsfeier in zwei wochen
auch wenn ich es darf mit 40 leuten
durchführen oder sollte man das
vielleicht mal dieses jahr verkleinern
diese dinge wie machen wir das mit
besuchen im familienkreis wie können wir
immer und opa zwar sehen aber wie können
wir vereinbaren dass wir vielleicht als
familie vorher uns in eine kurze
quarantäne begeben kann man vielleicht
auf eine bestimmte art sich vorher auch
testen alle diese dinge die werden
gerade auf verschiedenen ebenen
natürlich auch in der politik mit
angedacht also wenn es jetzt zum
beispiel darum geht bei anti gen tests
vorwärts zu kommen da sind das natürlich
ganz wichtige überlegungen und szenarien
aber am ende muss doch jeder einzelne
mitdenken für sich selbst und für die
eigene familie und das ist schon
entscheidend
also ich glaube wir sind in deutschland
ungefähr so gut gewappnet wie in den
europäischen nachbarländern
es gibt ein paar grundlegende
unterschiede vielleicht zum beispiel
unsere familienstrukturen sind anders
wir haben mehr einpersonenhaushalte wir
haben weniger mehrgenerationenhaus halte
das spiel bestimmt eine rolle
wir haben eine extrem gute
informiertheit der bevölkerung das
spielt sicherlich eine große rolle
wir haben die instrumente des
öffentlichen gesundheitswesens
eigentlich da wo sie hingehören und die
sind nicht schlecht in deutschland wenn
auch das personal natürlich besser
ausgestattet werden könnte
aber insgesamt sollten wir uns nicht
einbilden dass wir in einer sonderrolle
sind oder irgendwie gesegnet sondern wir
sollten einfach uns klarmachen dass das
hier ein naturphänomen ist den wir früh
begegnen müssen nicht erst wenn es zu
spät ist dann wird es anstrengend und
mühsam und auch schmerzhaft und im
moment würde ich sagen wir sind insofern
in deutschland in einer guten situation
als dass wir noch ganz früh dran sind
das ganze gut beobachten können und alle
chancen haben früh einzuschreiten und
das tatsächlich zu kontrollieren also
ich halte es für möglich dass wir in
deutschland die das einmal diese zweite
welle praktisch verhindern können aber
das geht nur mit einer großen
konzentriertheit in der ganzen
gesellschaft und da liegt jetzt gerade
im moment wirklich die herausforderung